بعد اشهر طويله من بدء القتال في المنطقه
اوكرانيا تعلن عن اول نجاح لهجومها المضاد
في محيط مدينه بخموت التي تشهد اطول واعنف
معركه في اطار الهجوم الروسي اذا هنا
الهجوم المضاد الذي تحدثت عنه اوكرانيا
فبحسب قائد الجيش الاوكراني انكاز استطاعت
السيطره على عشره مناطق بضواحي مركز
المدينه واستطاعت ان تطرد القوات الروسيه
من هذه المنطقه وبحسب ما هو معلوم
مشاهدينا في ان الهجوم المضاد الذين نتحدث
عنه بدا من جهه الشمال وبالتالي من ليمان
وايضا من منطقتين كما هو معلوم حتى الساعه
من مارينكا ومن اذا هذه الجهات كلها
تستخدمها اليوم القوات الاوكرانيه لمحاوله
استعاده السيطره على بخموت التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه على حوالي 95% من
هذه المدينه التي دمرت بالكامل وطبعا ليس
فقط القوات الروسيه الموجوده هنا والتي
تقاتل في هذه المنطقه منذ فتره طويله
وانما هي وايضا قوات فاجنر الروسيه التي
تعتبر الخط الامامي وخط الهجوم الاساس
بهذه المعركه هنا تعويل اوكراني بالهجوم
المضاد على التدريب الذي قامت به القوات
الاوكرانيه بالفتره الماضيه اتحدث عن سته
اشهر قامت خلالها القوات الاوكرانيه
بتدريب قواتها على نمط مختلف من القتال
برومانيا بالمانيا والمناطق المجاوره لحلف
الناتو هناك تعويل ايضا على الاسلحه
الغربيه التي ستستخدمها اوكرانيا بالفتره
المقبله وبالفتره اللاحقه لاستخدامه بهذا
الهجوم المضاد وطبعا على الروح المعنويه
التي تعول عليها بشكل كبير والتي استفادت
منها بالهجوم المضاد
بالفتره الماضيه والتي قامت به منذ سته
اشهر واليوم هناك تعويل اساسي وتقول بان
القوات الروسيه ليس لديها هذه الروح
المعنويه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات